what camera and mic setup do I use so I
got a great question fun of my youtube
viewers dan love you guys who wrote in
on youtube you asked me a question Evan
what camera and mic setup do you usually
use so is a great question when I'm
starting something new I hate spending
money till I'm making money so I always
try something on the cheap bootstrap low
budget just to try to get it going and
see if this is something that's going to
work for me or not I created a whole
zucca guide on this as well the reason
why is because you may not like it right
like most people say i'm going to start
into something and maybe i'm going to
get into videos and i'm going to go up
by a camera a tripod a microphone and
all this stuff and then you do it for a
couple of weeks and you find it you
don't like it and then you end up you
burn all this money so always try to get
it to the point where you're making
money you're enjoying it you know you're
going to continue before you invest in
it so how i started with the camera I
start with my first it was a DSLR
whatever I had I think was an icon film
myself I to a flip and then I just went
the costco and started upgrading along
the way and the reason why the cost goes
because they had a 90 day return policy
so you could really test out a camera
but most of the camera stores were like
14 days only and so I kept upgrading
through costco to the point where i got
their highest and camera that they sold
which was a sony i think i still have it
here let me pull it up here it was a
sony handycam this was it it's a what
model is it I don't know it says HD ABC
HD handycam Oh HDR CX 160 this is
probably an old model now's maybe over a
year old the reason I went with this it
was the only version a costco that had
an external microphone jack so one of
the things that's important is getting
good audio right so most of my earlier
videos there was no audio was just using
the camera microphone and people started
complaining to say hey great video but
we'd love to have better audio so i had
to go find a camera that had an external
mic jack and this is the only
one that costco sold so i got this and i
use this for at least a year it has a
little tripod plug in here so i bought a
tripod from a camera store and just
stood in front of the camera and that's
what I use for a while I went to the
sony store and there's just a little
clip Mike nothing special just a little
clip mike i think it was like 90 bucks
whatever their you know base model was
and it's still the one I use today i
recently upgraded my camera a couple
months ago maybe to a new canon that
i'll pull up let me find it here i'm
sure you know so i can't show you but
this is the box it is a canon xa10 so I
I love this camera it's great when I was
getting into buying a new camera the
reason why I did it so the Sony was
great no problems with it Christina who
edits all my videos hi Christina she
likes to punch in on my videos so you
know you see me here and then you'll see
me you know zoomed in here and then
you'll see just my face she likes to
punch in and now that she likes the pen
as I go through and so that's that's
great the problem was with the sony
camera whenever she zoomed in it lost
the quality so i needed to get a camera
that was that was higher quality and so
i was confused as a lot of research and
i got to the phone was like there are so
many options out there i don't know
which one to go with so I called up a
buddy of mine mark trigger from phantom
media and Mark basically went through
and showed me he picked a camera like
Mark here's my budget this camera cost
about two thousand dollars the sony one
from Costco is maybe four five hundred
dollars so as I do more videos I get
more it makes sense to invest more into
it he said this is a camera to go with
you know I wanted all automatic settings
I don't want to play around with
anything and so he picked the right one
and I trusted his advice and I went with
it and so far been really happy so the
total cost you know i'm looking at 2k
for the camera the the tripods maybe 100
bucks the microphone 90 bucks but you
can definitely start cheaper and i would
definitely encourage you to start
with something like you know that model
I costco or just start with what you
have right like it's not the tools it's
not the equipment it's it's how good you
are on camera right there are some
videos that are taking on on your iPhone
that if you are a powerful speaker and
you learn to get better right I've
gotten better because I've done over a
thousand videos you have to get better
you have to practice and you can start
with whatever you have right now you
don't have to go out invest in equipment
the better equipment will not save you
and I've always said it doesn't matter
about the lighting and the camera and
where I am like I've had some great
videos me walking on the street with my
with my samsung phone just recording me
practice and get better and make sure
you're you're you're impacting people
and you're happy that you're producing
and that you can justify spending money
I don't want you going out there
dropping a whole load of cash on the
equipment and then not continuing with
it and not producing quality products
that the production helps you know the
tools help but it that's it's minor it's
more about how good you are in speaking
on the cameras of practice practice
practice practice anyway that's what I
used in hopefully I answered your
question get out there and let me know
when you make your first video share
with me I want to check it out and I'll
leave a comment for you because you're
watching like the video please give it a
thumbs up below let me know what you
think leave a comment below ask me a
question below i'll make a video
response and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel get more videos
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it and I'll see you soon